hey we're running late hi I'm Liza Koshi
hi my name is markiplier hi i'm hannah
hart and welcome to creator support
Samak cookie how do you guys define
success and how did you know you made it
on YouTube I'll never say that I've made
it like I'll never have it more I'm like
yeah this is dude I got my certain 2011
there wasn't success on YouTube I was
just happy that I could create content
and post it and that people like to
watch it I defined success by doing what
makes you truly happy for me success is
derived by the amount of pride I taken
the work that I do at Lilly and Sam asks
your opinion is very needed how many
times a week should I post a video on
YouTube as many times as you can
mentally physically and emotionally
handle whenever you have something
worthy of sharing if you put up garbage
you're gonna feel like garbage are you
going to be completely beholden to the
expectations set by content hungry
teenagers are you going to set out a
creative path and lead your audience we
don't do that yo kita bcs how long does
it take to create a youtube video for
you it takes me dude you're looking at
the entire production company right now
I write everything by myself and I shoot
everything by myself
it takes me a very long time to create a
three-minute so five minute video a
Leone man a Leo or a lion man why did
you start making videos on YouTube for
me it started out as a joke I made a
video for somebody that I loved and I
sent it to them via YouTube it went
viral and now I work in entertainment I
was really bored I had a lot of voices
in my head and I decided to put a wick
on them and a mustache on them and start
giving them names and I'm fine it was a
way for me to express myself and to kind
of have fun
well actually we didn't start making
videos on YouTube somebody took videos
we had made not on YouTube and put them
on YouTube but that person that took
those videos they're dead now I started
making videos because I didn't like
where my life was going I was at a low
point just came out of a surgery to
remove a tumor bad relationship got laid
off from my job so I needed some
semblance of control in my life Let's
Plays were something that were easy to
grasp I felt like I could start out on
doing it and actually have something to
make and then I could build on it from
there and started doing sketches and
stuff McKenna rash something I'm still
trying to get rid of what do you guys do
when you have a disagreement how do you
solve it it's
not slaps its left that's when you limp
handedly I give up I won that creative
argument next question okay Liza Koshi I
know you get this a lot but I need
advice I really want to start vlogging
but I hit some mental roadblock every
time he'll set aside the time that you
have for writing or creating and set
aside some time for really believing in
yourself and loving yourself and
appreciating what you do Harry
aru since I'm about to reach 1k subs in
a few months on YouTube how do you want
me to celebrate it once the milestone is
reached however you want to I tried to
do the cinnamon challenge and I ended up
inhaling cinnamon and I had to go the
doctor afterwards so don't do that one
time I was did a 12 hour live stream
called thanketh on congealed pork blood
and a taco would be a great way for you
to celebrate at meg dragon I would love
to hear more about the mechanics of it
all how long does an idea take from
concepción to posting tell us nerd stuff
nerd stuff please it's all in my head
and I'll start giggling and then it's
some form of a dick joke that usually
gets tapered down into an idea where I
can make it a punchline of a video we
have to produce so much content at this
point that no one has the balls to say I
don't think that's a good idea if I have
something that is appropriate for 280 or
less characters I do Twitter if I have a
video concept I do YouTube and so now
what happens is we're just like yeah
that's great and then we do it and if
it's not good we just have another video
the next day get over it at 1 2 1 4
McGuire may I ask if all people how did
you get into the pro-ams oh the pro-am
that's the fortnight tournament I was
very curious about that myself I'm a big
guy for charity I do a lot of charity
events so I think that was the main
reasoning for it Regan lingered ass how
did you create your characters like
Helga ilysm which means I live so much I
think so much - Helga was something that
actually created among my friends sounds
like a Russian character about know
where she's from I ain't gonna say where
she's found cuz that might offend
someone so you know I'm just gonna
refrain from that I think the voice for
Helga came first and then kind of her
like interesting hunchback that comes
along with it it's kind of like a mother
that has been through a lot of stress
and never got massage that Kimiko - how
do you tubers make money from YouTube
someone
me they are paid for subscribers and
views question please use or do they
just get paid for ads and collaborations
I don't think you get paid for
subscribers which is sad you do get paid
for views advertisers pay to have their
ads shown in front of YouTube videos
they don't specifically sell to you they
sell through YouTube through YouTube's
ad system you get a share of that it's
like this you're the fraction of an
amount there's a bunch of factors
outside of that that have nothing to do
with you that effect whether that
fraction is bigger or smaller the other
way is brand you'll see work
specifically with a company to make
money the other way is selling merch to
your fans directly or other things like
music on iTunes or whatever have you and
there are some people are experimenting
with a donate button have you heard
about this I didn't know about it button
yeah it's a donate button donate what I
think it's old clothes at Dom Kalin Dom
Colin Dom Kalin Dom Kalin does YouTube
bread bring any revenue for creators
yeah it does you get a share of YouTube
read revenue based on watch time people
have a subscription to YouTube bread and
then that split among creators dependent
on watch time we have at mad X stitcher
how did you come to terms with the idea
that strangers on the internet probably
want to sleep with you that's the sweet
they do I am taken and spoken for so
thank you and I appreciate it but go
away I think that's a big compliment and
that's really creepy you want to sleep
with me you're also sleeping with my
wife and my dog I do have a California
king so I do have room in my house I
don't think you ever really come to
terms with that man you're just like
really wow you got great taste at Sal VB
I was wondering if you had any advice on
changing video titles a week or two
after posting as a way of a be testing
any thoughts
I have changed my titles before we do
this but you didn't hear it here the
first day that a video is posted is
going to be the most important think
about what you would click on on YouTube
and then title it that if you feel like
changing something up change it up do it
why not what you have to do is be
confident in the decisions that you're
making as a creator we actually don't
wait a week or two we wait like an hour
or two since those are the only things
we can change and those are
things we do change boom is Lord 69 how
do you guys film GMM do you film every
episode for the weekend one day and edit
it later or do you film the episode the
night before we found all 1400 episodes
in 2012 back-to-back and we're getting
it's not very very close to running out
next question at legit skeller
jacksepticeye and markiplier and cry was
taken how did you come up with your
YouTube name's Sean mark Ryan not that
you guys will see this you don't even
know I exist a lull me and my girl love
you guys though wish you would collab
with Ethan - he's adorable
my brother actually came up with my name
my original intention on YouTube was to
make sketch comedy where I play all the
characters I didn't know how to do that
but the name still stuck I am mark and I
was going to multiply myself
therefore markiplier wheel zoe marshall
says how do you tell your parents you've
decided to do YouTube and play video
games for a living
well my friend I'm 31 so don't need to
do you do YouTube it and play video
games for a living as in you make a
steady paycheck because then your
parents have a real distinct answer and
you're just like oh okay you're paying
your bills you were doing well you're
doing good I do not encourage you
jumping train abandoning everything else
and diving into YouTube before you've
even started it James Seymour how did
you guys come up with the let's talk
about that intro originally we thought
our show was just gonna consist of us
talking about stuff things topics we
were gonna banter friend Lily then it
turns out we had to start eating
coagulated pork blood and tacos and the
anuses and testicles of several all type
of flora and fauna at by for gaming asks
what is the hardest part of making
consistent YouTube content ADHD yeah I
lose interest really quick having a
vision and being able to make it come
true you're cynical comments seeking to
not build your self-esteem on people's
perception of you which is exactly what
we have done which is an incredibly
unhealthy way to exist I feel like a
ghost of a person make sure you get into
a nice routine if you tell yourself that
you're gonna create on Wednesdays make
sure that you're riding on Sunday and
then filming on Monday and then editing
on Tuesday and posting on that Wednesday
I've tiny dancer 74 says hey lady I'm
starting a vlog and was wondering what
equipment slash software you like to use
for your videos - I which also means the
I got my start using literally my webcam
on my laptop
I shot him photo booth and I imported it
into iMovie now I have a Canon 60d I
have a rode on-boarded Mike and I edit
in Adobe Premiere that she could be good
what's the best video you ever made
we've never seen corrupted deleted or
never uploaded I didn't upload it
because it was inappropriate okay
honestly any video that I have chosen
not to upload was boring there was an
entire sketch that we filmed we only
needed one shot left the SD card that it
was all on just disappeared the backups
that we made to the computer we're all
corrupted sometimes are gonna make some
things that you're not the most proud of
ever that you're not super into it's
fine just keep creating we need to
consult our PR person should we tell the
story about no but we'll change the name
yeah we were once making a video with
fire at tanks supermodel super smaadahl
in a waffle iron think about it you've
never seen fire uh tanks left hand and
if you do there will be a noticeable
grid on it
Elite Shaka I'm gonna say what youtubers
do you guys watch have you ever watched
Jen's kitchen lovely Japanese man cooks
or his cats
I watched Anna Marbles on YouTube I
watched Ryan Higa on YouTube i watch the
fine brothers on YouTube I watched
kurzgesagt which is also called in a
nutshell they are a informational
animation channel we only watch our own
video to flee just reverse it it's hard
to find good stuff to watch on YouTube
so we just watch Lincoln Rhett yep
and primitive technology oh yeah it's
good there's also cyanide and Happiness
and bro science life and 40k theories
which is for Warhammer 40k which I'm a
big fan of and I don't talk about hi
markiplier I have a question how did you
get noticed with your YouTube channel or
at what point my first exposure was the
first reaction compilation that I made
which is just an assembly of funny
moments in my gaming career I posted it
on YouTube and it got posted to Reddit
and it just so happened to get to like
third place on the video section of
Reddit and suddenly I got subscribers
Christina what can't my parents
understand how important it is for me to
go to VidCon the moment your parents
understand why you should be at VidCon
you will no longer want to
VidCon is very expensive your parents
have bills to pay if you're a huge fan
of someone if you explain that you've
been watching them for years they've
supported you you've gotten a lot of
inspiration from them that's one reason
good old Ron Moray how many production
hours go into GMM pre video posts proud
to say my 16 year old has heard of your
show awesome work guys
words good know it would be embarrassing
if we actually did the math on that and
gave you the real number that went into
12 to 15 minutes of content every single
day it's more than you think is
necessary as is evidenced by the fact
that every time we post a picture of our
crew the first question is why do you
need so many people at ire about what is
the best way to make a call to action
really work best way to make a call to
action really work is to make an actual
logical argument to your viewer base as
to why this is important
I do these call to actions on charity
efforts ask small these fans these
people supporting you they are your fans
they believe in you and they believe in
what you're doing
well the knock Bard knocked Bard
nocturnal Bard
am i a bad human being for feeling super
aggravated when someone tells you to
like and subscribe more than once in a
YouTube video
I feel like creators should focus on a
good impression instead of begging for
subs maybe I'm just tired and grumpy
today
I completely agree with you we do it in
every single episode we say liking
commenting and subscribing we do it once
I understand why you get super
aggravated by it but it's a way for a
creator to measure whether or not a new
format that they're testing out is
working I feel like if the content is
good it will stand on its own if the
videos are bad leave don't watch my
stuff if you enjoy it I'm gonna keep
pushing myself to make better stuff and
that's what should matter well thanks
for all your your questions I don't
usually give advice like this but I do
have some knowledge in my head if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
support from creators click like and
subscribe also make sure to keep doing
what you love and creating what makes
you happy and others thank you so much
for watching bye bye
we didn't help anybody we helped one
person someone named Patrick I'm sensing
Patrick this was for you